in shocked Mexico the 17th of October
2019 the day the Sinaloa cartel turned
out like an army with a devastating
array of firepower they subjugated the
Mexican military itself and took over
the streets of Culiacan
this man says he was there fighting with
the cartel we're talking about their
weapons well most of the people they're
in on the side of the cartel armed with
American guns oh yes of course because
all of the arms that we use here are
from the other side of the border he's a
hitman a soldier for organized crime one
of the many across Mexico responsible
for a record murderer how difficult
would it be to do your job if there
wasn't this free flow of arms coming
from the United States it would be hard
because the u.s. is the chief supplier
that's where we get the new exclusive
guns we need of the guns that have been
seized in Mexico and traced 70% come
from the United States there's a reason
it's hard to get a gun legally in Mexico
the regulations are extremely strict not
so in the US and cartels you straw
buyers in gun shops in shows to get
Glocks ak-47s ar-15s and even machine
guns it's this man's job to smuggle them
across the border that is very easy to
get them across we do hide them in the
upholstery or where we can but the
customs agents here don't really focus
on that on searching you they never
search the car we saw that for ourselves
when we made the journey from the u.s.
into Mexico on a busy Thursday night
there were no passport controls we saw
no border officers and just two customs
officials check to see of cars we're
already through we're into Mexico
a lack of vigilance which is hard to
reconcile with Mexico's concerns let
myself go confess the most worrying
issue in Mexico are the guns the guns
that we saw in Culiacan were impressive
I want to propose again that using the
latest technology from both countries we
can stop the arms traffic at the border
we asked for an interview with Mexico's
foreign ministry and its customs agency
to to discuss those border security
plans we didn't hear back meanwhile
quantities of weapons continue to be
brought across they're stashed in a
multitude of safe houses on arrival The
Gun Runners in charge of this one in a
suburb of the border town Mexicali
anymore gone when we come back with guns
they can stay here a day or two and then
our people come to get them when
everything is ready
they take them away they're distributed
throughout the country being caught with
one should mean jail time but if the gun
runner's get stopped by local police
there's a simple solution if they stay
here with money the dog dances he sorted
it all out with cash and then we each go
our own way I don't know you and you
don't know me
the guns make their way to the cartel
soldiers the same ones that battled and
beat MIT scanned authorities on the 17th
of October his confrontation between the
cartel and the government in Culiacan
that wouldn't have happened if the
Sinaloa cartel hadn't had this easy
access to weapons no yes it would have
happened but obviously as you say it
would have been hard for us without that
number of weapons I mean we probably
wouldn't have beaten them if it wasn't
so easy to get hold of the guns the
Mexican forces humiliation then an
indirect consequence of lean US gun
regulations and this country's
insufficient border security but there
are other consequences too more intimate
ones for the thousands of victims of
Mexico shootings in part to will tell
their stories John Holman al Jazeera
Mexicali